you're so busy running and competing for
meetings and times that the ability to
stop and pause and recharge your
batteries and think broader and much
deeper was really a terrific opportunity
what i took from scp and what i think
i'm doing differently is
consciously thinking about not only what
i need to do today but how that bridges
to where the business goes in the future
as well
one of the highlights of coming to
stanford was it is right in the middle
of the technology corridor to be right
in the heart of the silicon valley i
think it's a huge benefit
to think differently to
be more open to the ideas and concepts
and to really define how we serve
customers in a differentiated way is
really a great part of being right here
scp i consider an incredible investment
in me as a leader think about the
incredible investment my family made
it's in the middle of summer your kids
are out of school how do i balance all
that and i would say
make the time because you'll have so
much more to give back to others
one of the really key benefits of the
program is building a global network
that enables you to think differently
not only about what we do here in the us
but around the world as well
coaching and developing and sending
talent to programs such as scp really
enables companies to maintain relevancy
maintain a competitive edge and maintain
a leadership position
don't be the person who has all the
answers but rather be the leader who
facilitates a different kind of
conversation as a result of what you've
learned
our credo which is what we live by says
our best was good for today tomorrow we
will do better the investment verizon
made for me to attend scp has made me a
better leader and in return i believe i
make the business better every day
i really believe that scp was
transformational because it gave me a
platform on which to think about the
business differently and in thinking
about the business differently to
deliver different kind of performance
results it will be the best investment
you've ever made